here in round can we go take casteniuk's  game she's about to deliver checkmate  okay eric canton and she's done it she's  sacrificed her queen  and she wins the chess queen wins her  first game of the tournament  they're both smiling and so yeah well  well i mean even though that kind of  ruins eric's talk well it doesn't ruin  it but it's good to see him smile that's  really nice i mean you know  what a way to finish it as well just to  explain the current position white has  just given up the queen but after  black's knight goes and catches the  white queen white's rook is going to  zoom up to the top of the board and trap  the black king in the corner beautiful  finish and  she's deserved it perseverance pays off  yeah look at eric of course he's super  disappointed because he is fighting to  qualify he is currently now in fourth  place i think